gonna know people that die from these
but never thought for a minute being my
dad and my sister five days apart it
happened all very quickly stories of
loss families of those who died of
covid-19 opened the inquiry with their
devastating testimony and she died alone
five days
they hope the inquiry will answer the
question could these deaths have been
avoided I intend to answer the following
three questions
was the UK properly prepared for a
pandemic
was the response to it appropriate and
can we learn lessons for the future
Witnesses over the next few weeks could
include former Prime Minister David
Cameron and former Health Minister
Jeremy Hunt and questions will be asked
as to why despite pandemic simulation
exercises in 2016 when epidemiologists
warned the country was unprepared for a
pandemic none of the 22 recommendations
were acted on
it was Dr Musa Qureshi who campaigned
for the government to make the results
of those exercises public some of the
findings for instance of exercise Alice
which was a secret coronavirus exercise
which government ministers never
admitted had happened until we forced
disclosure some of the findings were
that we did not have enough
infrastructure so we didn't have enough
PPE we didn't have enough intensive care
beds or intensive care capacity and that
may well have been a decision in line
with the long policy of austerity which
has cut NHS beds over years rather than
increasing the inquiry will ask why was
there a shortage of personal protection
equipment for health workers where was
the planning for extra hospital beds and
did austerity reduce the UK's capacity
to prepare for a pandemic the next stage
of this three-year process will look at
the decisions the government made
including why two days after the who
declared the pandemic thousands gathered
to enjoy horse races in Cheltenham in
England when other countries in Europe
were already locked down as the inquiry
put it this natural disaster was
unavoidable but was the devastating
impact inevitable scientists are clear
that the risk of future pandemics is
ever increasing what these families want
to know is Will lessons be learned
quickly enough to protect people before
another one strikes Charlie Angela Al
Jazeera London